[Music]
if I told you about her
the princess without voice what would I
say
[Music]
[Music]
she deaf mute she can hear you you clean
that lab to get out this may very well
be the most sensitive asset ever to be
housed in this facility
you may think that thing looks human
stands on two legs right but we're
created in the Lord Jim you don't think
that's what the Lord looks like me this
creature is intelligent capable of
language of understanding emotions
[Music]
when he looks at me he doesn't know how
I am incomplete he sees me as I the
natives in the Amazon wears a different
God get him out no need to take it apart
learn how it works I don't want an
intricate beautiful thing destroyed we
could do nothing I'm sorry
don't do this alas sir what is she sighs
don't do this that's not even you
if I told you about her what would I say
I wonder
[Music]
maters always say Tonya tell the truth
[Music]
there's no such thing as truth everyone
has their own truth
I was the best figure skater in the
world at one point in time
[Music]
call out a clean skate stop talking to
her that girl is your enemy Jeff was my
first date ever and my mom came to see a
wholesome American family I don't have a
wholesome American family well that's
every year fault was embarrassed for you
my entire life I've been told when
amounts anything
you know what maybe I would
oh boy how do I get a fair shot here we
also judge on presentation didn't even
even the place I know God shouldn't even
be saying his name Derek I never did
this
[Applause]
always going on we're with the FBI they
know something what can you tell us
about Tonya Harding
I don't know it Toni hearted huh
aren't you her bodyguard when I was a
kid did you ever love me I made you a
champion knowing you'd hate me for it
that's the sacrifice a mother makes
accursed me come on
what kind of friggin person bashes in
their friend's knee who would do that to
a friend
stop that when I found you I saw raw
untamed power and beyond that something
truly special something beside me has
always been
[Music]
but I was awake I need help
[Music]
I've seen this raw strength only once
before it scared me enough that
it does now
[Music]
but the pastime
kill it
if you have to
that's the only way to become what you
meant to be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the fire
this is not going to go
[Music]
where you think
[Music]
I need someone to show me my place in
all this
[Music]
[Music]
yep that's me I'm Ferdinand is like very
big your ginormous more beetle of very
strong ready to put those wings to work
oh oh no you shot Maria into the Sun
sorry family attempt was the good boy
but the world sees Ferdinand is one
thing a fighter I am here detectable
with my hunts for my instruments as are
my arms next chest and buttocks no I'll
pass thanks
you guys go ahead I know exactly how
certain it feels let's go out there and
give it 110% ahead actually I'm gonna
pass on the violence
- friendly ready to fight come on I am
NOT a fighting boy movie sends a message
that resonates very strongly with me
don't judge a bull by his cover there
are places out there we don't get pushed
around for being yourself heads for one
and hog for everybody
[Music]
from the creators of Ice Age and we owe
I'm getting out of this place just try
to be a little more the door to freedom
just do exactly what we do exactly as we
do New York is the greatest thing in the
world
my city I was a kid in these streets and
I made it to the top I made my bombs
doing a piece of work for Don Carlo
Gambino like that that became a made man
dad I'm thinking maybe take a year off
you wanna hang out with me do you know
what you're doing to this family I will
build something that nobody can destroy
so well Castle ah was a fish in the
desert I never respected Paul you killed
the boss's boss
you will bring down Hellfire there is no
choice you'll need the support of all
five boroughs Queens Brooklyn Manhattan
Staten Island the Bronx our job now is
to maintain leadership I nominate John
Gotti let everybody off now everybody
comes to this I'm sure proud you should
be running your own crew now mr. Gotti
are you the head of the Gambino crime
family the head of my family
mrs. Bobby do you know what your husband
does for a living they provide John's
getting too much press that can't go
unchecked it was meant for you
we've never been in this kind of
scrutiny before what were you saying in
the tapes I said a lot of things that
could get a lot of people in trouble dad
said we're don't go for a cliff for you
you mean that you would not bring him
into that well this life of ours is a
wonderful life if you can get away with
it
Johnson has been an informant for the
FBI
order you fight - you can't fight no
more
never back off ever
[Music]
we walked together and we fall together
this is the life I found something you
gotta check this out
you place board games anymore
yo what's this
[Applause]
Jumanji pick a character and you're that
person in the game
Bethany went it'll spend my life staring
at a TV screen
it's my hair
which was to me
oh my god we're in different people's
party Stephanie don't look at it I'm an
overweight middle-aged man wait a second
where's my phone
don't cry don't cry don't cry talker
I think we've become the avatars we
charge welcome to Jumanji
this is a video game which means reads
have to be lives come on let's go I'm
out watch you step in here so gnarly we
can help each other we all have special
skills
[Music]
none I hate this game everybody else got
good stuff weakness Hey
yes cake is my weakness no good weapons
valet what is that I think it means you
carry my weapon - give them to me when I
tell you to
don't let this new body get your butt
water we have to work together I think
it's a staring contest who's good at
staring and not blinking hands I'm
amazing at it
[Music]
I like can't even with this place
[Music]
we gotta get on my back
no no I'll carry you come on I would
rather die get on my back no I'm going
down
[Music]
pound cake cake isn't that your weakness
nothing happened to me am i shaking I'm
not still black yes this is the moment
you've waited for I'm not you're still
just the tailor sport better luck with
your next job those people will never
accept us this is the life I promised
you not even close
I have everything I want
[Music]
girls getting together a shot it's the
place where people can see things have
never seen before
okay who's and what is your act I know
so have an axe everyone's gotten act
people aren't gonna like it put us on
stage no I'm counting on it
I believe those are the words of a
scoundrel shell whistling does a shaman
to listen to them they don't understand
yet but they will
so tell me do you wanna go
[Music]
if possible come true it's taking over
you
does it bother you that everything
you're selling is fake to the smile seem
fake we have more protesters every day I
try to print you're risking everything
you do how do you think I've built
[Music]
but you put us in a spotlight you gave
us a real family how do you know she
father the world is changing
[Music]
we never made a difference by being like
everyone else
over 17 million fathers in the u.s.
inventive fathers and lenok brave but
not everyone knows who their father is
for 40 years we thought we did until
today I wasn't sure who your father was
that works too crazy sex monogamy wasn't
exactly a priority I've always wondered
where I got my zest for lovemaking now
we know our father's been out there this
whole time operation who's your daddy
the top mission is signing dad
submission is gonna be having Stone
Crabs mission below that getting you
laid mom actually dated Terry Bradshaw
do you remember a woman named Helen
Baxter talk about a blast from the past
she had the tightest ass you've ever
seen mouth and that time and a set of
knockers mom damn near cost us a Super
Bowl she's our mom why did you just stop
this foolishness this is it what are you
doing here anything were your sons
excuse me for a minute
oh it runs hot just like you well if the
man arrived he could easily be a serial
killer are you a serial killer I am NOT
a serial killer
you just emphasize the word serial like
I'm a killer but I'm not a serial killer
but out of cochlea intense you're still
not saying I promise I'm not a killer we
can give you a ride but those aren't too
tight are they almost kill you can't
kill you
[Music]
who was that I think it was a person the
universe has a tendency to point in the
right direction yes guys my negro spider
sense is tingling
not all training has the name Helen
Baxter ring a bell it does more than
ring a bell she was like a dick
whisperer
she's our mom all we did was cut the
extra-large is available in cayenne moss
and our version has six now and the plum
black I really want plum do you think
Moss is pretty you know I don't know
lady why don't you just pick a color
please Steve Johnson he never struck me
as the kind of guy who'd go get small
Wow so the decision to downsize things
takes pressure right off especially
money pressure you look like King Oh
time to move we're really strapped you
want my advice
Lee's your lands where you want to be in
leisure land your hundred thousand
dollars translates to 12 million dollars
Wow
I just got another diamond bracelet
pretty nifty huh okay go for it nervous
little today you will undergo the
permanent and irreversible procedure
known as downsizing Oh
granny you've got a call Paul don't be
mad at me please don't be mad I can't
leave my family I can't leave my friends
I'm sorry Paul I should have been
thinking about myself thinking about
yourself 95 you just saw as large as you
can please
I noticed we put a pretty big dent
anyone's self-esteem but downsizing is
about hitting the reset button start all
over world is filled with things to see
he's really sick you helped her
these are the people that we should be
helping
[Music]
something very big happening something
top-secret why did I downsize so that I
could be here right now I finally have a
chance to do something that matters I
think we're in the normal world and
something happens oh my god you realize
we're not ready let's do it one two
three
windows up grab it like you stole it put
on the castle
[Music]
officer Borg what happened I got a dude
in my car and the whole world is
watching relations first orcish police
officer I can't [ __ ] up my pension hey
don't get me stabbed wire voice always
got to be the bad guys so that night we
responded to a 415 disturbance car
immediately took fire [ __ ] can you make
a shootout akward weapon that grants
wishes and it just went really sideways
from that point on this a magic struck
and kill
a little trouble my position coming we
have to protect the wand so I need to
know if that you got my back you cop
first or and pork first it's time to end
this
[ __ ] you I want it down first do it
we're gonna titty bar gunfight dive
dreams are the nightmares
feels like a song on the pieces to me
butterfingers we were doing so good
[Music]
are we friends I think we should spend
our time just trying to survive this
year
[Music]
we'll be heroes forever
I need you to take your fat Shrek
looking ass back to [ __ ] home to Fiona
all right
[Music]
you carry your gun mr. chase never
bothered ruins a lot of your suit you
used to be a spy
my child's a prisoner 17 million dollars
father will take his pie is near
my former father-in-law only buys the
best time for you to do whatever it is
he pays you to do
hope you're half as good as everything
else exported we need a better answer
mr. Yeti do not have the money to spare
no one has ever been richer than you are
at this moment what would it take for
you to feel secure more
protect from every threat
unless the threat
that was two people
Paul Paul I didn't hire an ex-cia
officer just to pay people off aren't
you the two things other people can't or
won't do we have to be to walk away it's
my son I can't walk
I don't think this is about money it's
about power power business
tell them I'm coming
No
[Music]
so can I ask you a hypothetical question
oh dear I don't like hypothetical
question no I don't think you're gonna
like the real one either do you have the
papers yet
this is a devastating security breach
that was leaked out of the Pentagon the
most highly classified documents of the
war the time says 7,000 pages detailing
how the White House has been lying about
the Vietnam War for 30 years the way
they lied those days have to be over
okay people are concerned about having a
woman in charge of the paper that she
doesn't have the resolve to make the
tough choices Thank You Arthur for your
frankness let's do our jobs find those
pages you're talking about exposing
years of government secrets is that
legal
what is it you think we do here for a
living kid then I might have something
must be precious cargo just government
secrets
the New York Times was part publishing
any more classified documents dealing
with the Vietnam War and you'd publish
will be the supreme court next week
meaning we could all go to prison to
make this decision to risk her fortune
and the company that's been her entire
life well I think that's brave if the
government wins the Washington Post no
cease to exist and if we don't hold them
accountable who will can't hold them
accountable we don't have a newspaper
Nixon will muster the full power of the
presidency and if there's a way to
destroy you by god he'll find it I'm
asking your advice Bob not your
permission she can't do this the legacy
of the company is at stake
what will happen if we don't publish
we will lose the country will lose
what are you going to do mrs. Graham I'm
Molly bloom do you know about me
this is a true story you ran a games in
LA for roughly eight years yeah then you
ran games in New York for Russia - I
don't run a game in over two years not
to spoil the ending but that's when the
government raided my game and took all
of my money assuming all of it was made
illegally which it wasn't in this room
you couldn't buy your wine from olive
you couldn't buy me then you couldn't
buy a seat at the table when we saw
athletes
billionaires that's just the tip of the
iceberg
you're not taking percentage of the pot
no keep it that way because you don't
break the law when you're breaking the
law breaking the law we're able to find
out for sure
aren't we laws are written down the
admin is NLA about your book of life
right I did you spent eight years boning
the world's most exclusive glamorous and
decadent mancave for the office
guarantee the publisher has certain
elements and I can get you a million and
a half what kind of elements I passed
I'm just curious as to why you pass on
what would appear to be the only way out
you have these real names creative
differences the law that I'm accused of
breaking des Plantes gambling is betting
on games of chance yes pokers in a game
of chance pokers a game of skill
why does he have a woman at 22 has a
gold-plated resume
why does she run her games risk is nuts
you're gonna get blown up
you got 2.8 million on the street right
now if that money should be in your
hands just out deep into the Russian mob
where you
there's a new offer on the table
completely we handle it Audra you've
seen what's on those hard drives family
slags careers will be ruling why are you
in this alone whenever the people you're
protecting by not telling the whole
story it's not their names I'm
protecting charlie my
because it's 9 things
[Music]